There are a lot of ideas that I'm passionate about.
Um, and I spoke at the Institute
about one I'm particularly passionate about,
and that's empowering people
and, in fact, to empower people to own their own data,
to have a feeling of ownership and empowerment
about their own data.
I was thinking that data about people's own self
could be considered like a song
that they have copyrights to
and that they should feel empowered
to be able to exchange the data about themselves
for goods and services
or for other data
in a way that has transparent value to them
because right now, I and I think a lot of people
feel frustrated about these, you know, privacy policies
and other ways that people record data about you
where you don't really see clearly the value.
I gave the example that I had lost my passport,
and, in fact, I'm a day late getting here.
And, at the time, I thought,
"Well, how silly! I have this little booklet.
Why can't I just walk up to the kiosk
and it can take an image of my face
and look at all my data."
I would expose a vast amount of data to them
for a limited time
for the purpose of verifying my identity,
not so they can keep that forever
and use it for marketing
or whatever model-building purposes
that they have,
that's not part of the deal.
I would like a clear and transparent deal.
I let you see this
for this purpose,
for this time,
in exchange for this value,
and I'm okay with that, right,
if it's clear to me what the value is.
I'm willing to give more,
and I would like to see
these clear and transparent contracts
existing in plain language
with the proper potential digital controls
to make you accountable that you don't use my data
in sneaky other ways, right,
so that I trust you.
And when there's trust,
you know, then there can be an exchange.
And when there's an exchange for value,
I think we're building an economy,
a personal data economy.
And I think that will make people creative.
I think that will make people entrepreneurial
about collecting more data about themselves,
you know, talking,
giving more insights about themselves,
like some people would go to Mechanical Turk
and participate.
Some people would go to surveys and participate
because they get value back.
And that's what I'd really like to see.
I'd like to see companies offering real value
in exchange for people's data
and not these pretty much impossible-to-interpret contracts,
and that's something I'm very passionate about.
Click any of these fortune cookies
to see your questions and follow-up questions explored.
Click this cookie to return to the intro video
and see what this series is all about,
or click this cookie to suggest
alternative questions,
participants,
or career paths
for future videos.